- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is Create What You Like.
Over to you, Seth Rogan.
(rooster crows)
("Entspresso" theme song)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- We make the movies we want to go see.
We found that when you go in meetings,
there's a lot of, you know, with studios
and various producers and stuff,
there's a lot of talk about
who will like the movies.
You know, you make this movie,
these people will like it.
You make this movie, and
And they're all kind of guesses,
stabs in the dark almost.
And then, that's when
we realize, you know,
the only people that we know
that we can make movies for
is ourselves.
So, when we sit down to write a movie,
like "Pineapple Express,"
we thought, what movie
do we want to go see?
What's the trailer that
we watch, that we say,
"that's the movie that I'm going
to throw down my money for.
That's the movie I
can't wait to go watch."
And, yeah, that's really all it is.
You know, you could guess all day,
as to what other people would like.
But you know what you like.
So, that's what we try to do,
is just stuff that we
would want to go see.
(whoosh)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
The question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what is the
last thing that you created
that you really really
really liked yourself?
You created for yourself?
What was the last thing that you made?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Noel Brosnan.
Noel, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word," it really
really really means a lot to me.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning,
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
Hey Believe Nation!
If you want to stay inspired
on creating the things that you like,
stay tuned for some special bonus clips.
- I don't think in terms of, like,
restrospectively or retroactively
looking at what I did and
how I got to where I am.
Instead, it's much more focused on,
what do I want to do next?
- Mmhmm.
- Because I think that
if you try to consider,
or cater to your audience too much,
you'll invariably end up
making something that's mush.
- Yeah.
- Because I don't know
that the audience knows
what they want to see.
I know that I don't know what's
going to pique my interest.
If I knew how to describe
the perfect movie,
blog, television show, I would just do it.
I want to see something that surprises me.
And, when I think of my own
work, that's exactly right.
Like, I put my head down,
and I try to ignore the world,
and I try to make something
that I think is really good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And if people like, it great.
If they don't, I don't
care, as long as I like it.
So I think that if I had
one thing to attribute
all of this growth to,
it's making work that I feel embodies
the same level of
integrity of anything else
that I would invest myself into.
- Do you have a specific target audience?
- Well just anybody who can
read, anybody who's literate.
It used to be, in Canada, comics
were just for little kids.
Or they were thought
to be for little kids.
- [Interviewer] But that's changed.
- Yeah, with Marvel, 'cause
we started directing Marvel
at ourselves, really.
The theory was, we're going
to write the kind of stories
we would enjoy reading.
You see?
And I didn't know if it would work or not.
But, it worked better
than anybody expected,
because, we grabbed a lot of
readers who are much older.
Who liked the kind of
things that we liked.
But we didn't lose the young kids.
So we ended up, we had kids
seven years old who read Marvel,
who don't understand
the subtle implications
and ramifications and the
psychology and philosophy
and the subliminal moralizing,
but they loved the nutty
characters and the long underwear
and the colorful costumes.
And, the older readers enjoyed
all the little subplots,
and the little asides we'd put in,
and the little things that a
young kid can't ever grasp.
But, they're there in the story.
- You've reached a happy medium.
- Yeah, so we find the best
formula, if you call it that,
is we don't try to write for any audience,
we try to write stories we would enjoy,
and apparently there are
enough people in the world
with the same tastes.
I hate to say that,
I'd like to think my taste is far better,
but apparently everybody
has got pretty much the same taste,
'cause the books sell pretty well.
- When it comes to pleasing people,
listen, of course you want
to have a good reception,
but, you don't make a
movie without committing.
And, so I'd have to make a
movie that I would want to see,
and I have to create a character
that I am interested in,
and that's it.
I put my head down, and I focus on that,
and I don't really pay attention
to what people may be requesting,
because I believe that if
we have enough conviction
in what we're doing, people
will believe it as well.
- Do you think the secret to your success,
is actually, you are, in many ways,
in the ways you lead your life,
your tastes are quite
average, middle-of-the-road,
the kind of stuff that the
mass market would like?
- For sure, absolutely right.
And I don't think you can make records,
I don't think you can
make TV shows properly,
unless you can sit there
as a listener or a viewer.
You can't guess what people like.
It would be like me guessing
what you want for dinner.
It's impossible.
I can tell you what I want.
So I base everything on my own tastes.
And I have, you know, fairly broad,
I'd say quite simple tastes.
- I think originality, period,
could crack not only the UK, anywhere.
Originality, people are
straying away from that.
Every time people do music or anything,
they do it like someone
who has done it before,
or they do it like what
think the people want.
I don't do that.
I do what I know is nice to me.
I do what I think is cool.
And if you don't think it's cool,
then I think you're not cool.
So, if you approach me with that attitude,
then I don't think you could ever lose.